Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Le Vendée Globe,
vous le connaissez, bien sûr.
Faites-vous partie des millions de
spectateurs venus découvrir cet événement
qui a lieu tous les quatre ans
aux Sables d’Olonne ?
Et faites-vous partie de celles et ceux
qui se sont réveillés en pleine nuit
pour jouer à Virtual Regatta,
pour bouger son petit bateau
ou encore pour découvrir la position
du bateau de son favori ?
Faites-vous partie de ceux
que le Vendée Globe fait rêver ?
Mais alors, pourquoi fait-il rêver ?
Parce que c’est une course à la voile
autour du monde,
en solitaire, sans escale
et sans assistance.
C’est la course à la voile
la plus dure au monde,
celle qui impose de se surpasser,
de dépasser ses propres limites
et parfois même
de faire preuve d’héroïsme.
Et c’est moi qui aie la chance, qui aie
l’honneur, qui aie la responsabilité
de cette épreuve hors normes.
Alors oui, j'ai bien conscience que je
dirige un événement pas comme les autres
et j’ai bien conscience qu’il faut
absolument en préserver les valeurs
car le Vendée Globe est unique.
En effet, connaissez-vous
une épreuve sportive
dans laquelle on acclame autant
le premier concurrent que le dernier ?
Eh bien, je vais vous raconter
l’arrivée du dernier concurrent
du Vendée Globe 2021.
Il s’agit d’Ari Huusela.
C’est un skippeur finlandais,
mais également un pilote de ligne.
Ari est inconnu du grand public.
Il pleure toute la nuit
précédant son arrivée.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien, parce qu’il vient d’accomplir
son rêve : terminer le Vendée Globe.
Et peu importe son classement.
Ce jour-là, l’hommage que lui rend
le public, malgré les restrictions,
malgré la pandémie,
est bouleversant de sincérité.
Et ce jour-là, moi, en le voyant,
j’ai également pleuré,
pleuré la fin de cette histoire.
Et puis pleuré de ne rien
avoir lâché non plus,
parce qu’il fallait l’organiser,
ce Vendée Globe, dans ces conditions-là.
Le Vendée Globe, vous l’aurez compris,
n’est pas une compétition
comme les autres.
En réalité, il s’agit surtout
d’une aventure, une aventure extrême,
mais surtout une aventure humaine,
une aventure profondément humaine.
Et c’est dans cette aventure
que je veux vous emmener,
je dirais même vous immerger
avec moi aujourd’hui.
Et tout d’abord,
le départ.
(Vidéo)(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
J’aime les départs de Vendée Globe.
J'aime les départs de Vendée Globe.
J’aime voir les bénévoles,
les équipes techniques,
les équipes de communication,
tous les partenaires,
l’ensemble du staff.
J’aime les voir travailler ce jour-là
avec professionnalisme.
Je me souviens en 2020 de leurs regards.
Je ne vois qu’eux.
Des regards concentrés, un peu nerveux.
Les procédures sont répétées
avec tellement de professionnalisme
que je suis exceptionnellement
fière de mes équipes.
Je suis fière, car je sais tout le travail
qu’il faudra pour en arriver là.
Les centaines de milliers de personnes
venues aux Sables d’Olonne
pour vibrer d’une seule et même émotion.
Un moment de communion intense.
Alors en 2024,
je suis sûre que vous serez là,
certainement à vous lever
à la première heure du jour
pour avoir la meilleure place
dans le chenal.
Le chenal, c'est une arène pour les
départs et les arrivées de Vendée Globe.
C’est ce chenal qui prend aux tripes des
skippers qui partent et qui reviennent.
Et les skippers,
ces femmes et ces hommes partis faire
le tour de la Terre le temps d’une saison.
Pour gagner ?
Ou pour revenir ?
Qu’ont-ils dans leur cœur ?
Et qu’ont-ils dans leur tête ?
Sont-ils émus ?
Ont-ils peur ?
Sont-ils impatients à l’heure
de réaliser leur plus grand rêve ?
Moi-même, je me pose toujours
ces mêmes questions.
Et puis,
je les observe.
Car ces moments sont des moments réservés.
Réservés à la famille, réservés aux amis
et réservés aux équipes
proches des skippers.
À tous ceux qui ne dormiront pas
non plus pendant de longs mois.
Et puis je me souviens
de Yannick Bestaven.
Yannick descend le ponton
pour rejoindre son bateau.
Et comme un acte prémonitoire,
il embrasse le coffret
qui encercle le trophée.
S’il savait que c’est le coffret qu’il
soulèvera plus de 80 jours plus tard
comme vainqueur !
Ces aux revoirs
me bouleversent toujours autant.
Et ils partent.
(Vidéo)(Musique)
Voix off : Top !
(Fin de la musique)
Les voilà partis
pour une aventure extraordinaire
qui va durer de nombreux mois en solitaire
et des aventures par dizaines vont
se succéder à partir de maintenant.
J’avais très envie aujourd’hui
de partager avec vous
les aventures qui m’ont marquée.
Celles qui ont écrit l’histoire
du Vendée Globe, qui le symbolisent.
Vous souvenez-vous, par exemple,
de Bertrand de Broc ?
Vous en souvenez-vous ?
Bertrand se coupe la langue
sur son bateau après un choc.
Vous savez ce qu’il a fait, Bertrand ?
Il l’a recousue tout seul,
avec l’aide d’une aiguille et d’un fil,
d’un petit miroir
et des conseils radio du médecin
de la course, M. Jean-Yves Chauve.
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez
également d’Yves Parlier ?
Yves Parlier a dû réparer son mât
pendant dix jours.
Il n’a plus rien à manger,
alors, il doit pêcher
et récupérer le sel sur son bateau
pour conserver ses aliments.
Il voulait revenir en vainqueur.
Finalement, il revient en héros.
Vous souvenez-vous de Raphaël Dinelli ?
Est-ce que vous vous en souvenez ?
Raphaël reste 36 h en mode survie
sur son bateau qui s’est renversé
au large des Kerguelen,
sans boire, sans manger
et avec une jambe qu’il ne sent plus.
N’est-ce pas héroïque ?
Et vous souvenez-vous
d’Ellen McArthur en 2001 ?
Ellen a 24 ans et elle arrive
deuxième du Vendée Globe,
juste derrière Michel Desjoyeaux.
Quel symbole, cette femme
sur le podium du Vendée Globe !
Parce que le Vendée Globe
est une épreuve au long cours,
tout n’est pas affaire
que de puissance physique.
Et les femmes ont totalement
leur rôle à jouer.
Et justement, en parlant de ces femmes,
vous rappelez-vous
ces six femmes en 2020 ?
Est-ce que vous vous en souvenez ?
De Clarisse Crémer ?
Premier Vendée Globe.
Diplômée d’HEC, elle bat
le record d’Ellen MacArthur.
N’est-ce pas incroyable ?
Miranda Merron, qui fait son tour du monde
alors même qu’à l’âge de neuf ans,
elle traverse l’Atlantique
sur le bateau familial,
et qui laisse tomber
sa carrière de publicitaire
pour s’adonner à sa passion,
la course au large.
Et Pip Hare, qui découvre la voile
en solitaire à l’âge de 35 ans.
Elle se définit comme une aventurière.
Pip n’hésite pas à prendre
sur ses propres deniers
pour aller jusqu’au bout
de son rêve de Vendée Globe.
Quel courage !
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de Samantha Davies et d’Isabelle Joschke ?
Quel sang-froid,
quel courage elles ont eu.
Après leur avarie,
elles ont dû rallier un port.
Elles ont réparé et elles sont reparties
finir leur tour du monde hors course.
Parce que ce qui compte
n'est pas uniquement la compétition.
Ce qui compte, c’est de finir.
Isabelle Joschke veut terminer son tour
du monde, c’est essentiel pour elle.
Et Sam.
Sam,
elle défend une cause supérieure.
En terminant son tour du monde,
elle sauve 103 cœurs d’enfants.
103 cœurs d’enfants.
Malgré les restrictions,
le public les attend aux Sables d’Olonne.
Elles sont ovationnées.
Vous ne vous souvenez peut-être pas
de l’arrivée d’Alexia,
mais je vais vous la raconter.
C’est la dixième femme et la dernière
à avoir terminé le dernier Vendée Globe.
C'est une sportive engagée.
C'est une grande sportive.
Néanmoins, elle subit un choc assez
traumatisant pour son dos sur son bateau.
Les jours précédant son arrivée,
elle ne peut que ramper
ou marcher à quatre pattes sur son bateau.
Elle ne peut pas se tenir debout.
Alors quelle dignité lui faut-il pour,
quand elle arrive aux Sables d’Olonne,
descendre de son bateau
et remonter seule !
Elle ne veut pas être aidée.
Elle remonte seule
vers la terre.
Je vous dirais que
cette femme me touche tellement.
Toutes ces femmes finalement
me touchent tellement.
Elles sont tout un symbole pour moi,
pour nous tous, pour nous toutes.
J’avais très envie également aujourd’hui
de vous parler d’une histoire
que vous avez certainement entendue
des centaines de fois.
Une histoire qui a été très médiatisée.
C’est l’histoire de Jean Le Cam
et de Kevin Escoffier.
Et je vais vous la raconter aujourd'hui
telle que je l'ai vécue de l'intérieur,
au sein de l'organisation,
aux Sables d'Olonne.
30 novembre 2020,
c’est le 22e jour de course.
Kevin Escoffier est classé troisième
à ce moment-là au Vendée Globe.
Il navigue dans une mer déchaînée,
dans les quarantièmes rugissants,
avec des vagues qui font plus
de cinq mètres de creux.
Les conditions sont terribles.
Quand, soudain,
un bruit dantesque.
« Je coule, je ne rigole pas.
Mayday !
Je coule.
Je ne rigole pas. »
Le bateau de Kevin s'est plié en deux.
Il est 14 h 46.
Kevin agit très vite.
Il allume sa balise de détresse,
prend sa combinaison de survie,
prend un couteau dans une poche
pour détacher le radeau à l’arrière
et se retrouve projeté en pleine mer
sur ce petit radeau.
Il est
14 h 50.
Quatre minutes.
Il a fallu quatre minutes à Kevin
pour se sauver la vie.
Kevin.
La balise de détresse.
Le signal est capté.
L'alerte est donnée.
Et à 7 500 milles de là,
aux Sables d’Olonne,
l’organisation,
toute l’organisation du Vendée Globe
est sur le pont.
L'heure est très grave.
Un homme à la mer.
C’est ce qu’on appelle une crise majeure.
On y est préparé
même si on la redoute.
Alors,
je vais rejoindre le bureau
de la direction de course.
C’est dans ce bureau
que tout va se passer.
C’est dans ce bureau que
les recherches vont être menées,
que les opérations de sauvetage
vont être suivies.
Ce bureau est fermé à clé.
Le directeur de course est enfermé
avec ses adjoints.
Je passe par une porte secondaire.
Je veux suivre
toutes les opérations de sauvetage.
À l’intérieur de ce bureau,
les traits tirés,
concentré, le directeur de course,
M. Jacques Caraës.
Derrière son écran d’ordinateur,
il quadrille un périmètre,
périmètre qui serait
celui de l’émission de la balise
et donc périmètre au sein duquel
Kevin Escoffier pourrait être présent
avec son radeau.
On se rend compte que
le skipper le plus proche de cette zone
d’émission de la balise est Jean Le Cam.
Alors,
peu importe la compétition sportive,
il faut aller rejoindre Kevin, le sauver.
Donc il est décidé
de dérouter Jean Le Cam.
Jean arrête sa course et part sur la zone
qu'on lui demande de rejoindre.
Et en arrivant sur zone,
après un moment, il voit Kevin,
il voit le radeau de Kevin, il voit Kevin,
ils se parlent.
Kevin veut rejoindre le bateau de Jean
à la nage, mais ce dernier refuse.
Je vous rappelle : des vagues
de plus de cinq mètres.
C’était trop dangereux,
donc Jean part manœuvrer,
et le temps de cette manœuvre pour
approcher le radeau, il perd de vue Kevin.
Plus de radeau, plus de Kevin,
plus de contact, plus rien.
La mer noire.
Et Kevin, lui, qu’est-ce qu’il
a décidé de faire, Kevin ?
Il fait nuit.
Il a éteint sa balise.
Il faut économiser de l'énergie.
Puis il s'est dit qu'il allait dormir.
Je vous rappelle
les vagues de cinq mètres.
Quel mental !
Quel mental a-t-il eu !
Je me sens bien incapable
de faire la même chose que lui.
Mais Jean ne voit pas
les choses de la même manière.
Maintenant qu’il l’a vu, maintenant
qu’il a perdu, il veut le retrouver.
Il veut le rechercher.
Il ne veut pas le laisser derrière lui.
Absolument pas.
J'observe Jean à l'écran dans le bureau
de la direction de course.
Merci Skype.
Je l'observe chercher Kevin désespérément.
Les recherches durent sept heures.
Sept heures,
c’est long, c’est très long.
PC course, il fait nuit.
La tension est montée d'un cran.
Plus personne dans les équipes n’ose se
regarder, se dire ce qu’il pense tout bas.
J’imagine qu’on a tous un peu imaginé tous
les scénarios possibles dans nos têtes.
Et je sens que mon rôle à ce moment-là
est peut-être d’être dans l’apaisement.
Mais on ne retrouve pas Kevin,
alors on détourne trois autres bateaux.
Et alors que les bateaux commencent
à arriver sur zone,
il y a un skippeur -
et c’est Jean - qui voit
une petite lumière
dans une vague très loin.
Il décide de suivre son instinct
et d’aller voir.
Et là, eh bien là, c’est la délivrance.
Parce que c'est Kevin.
C'est Kevin sur son radeau.
Kevin bien réveillé.
Et à 2 h 11 du matin,
M. Jean Le Cam sauve Kevin Escoffier,
resté onze heures
dans son petit radeau de survie.
En quelques secondes,
Jean Le Cam devient le Roi Jean.
Alors oui, il ne gagne pas le Vendée
Globe, mais il gagne nos cœurs.
N’est-ce pas un clin d’œil de l’histoire ?
Lui qui, onze ans plus tôt, s'était
retrouvé lui aussi au large du cap Horn,
sur son bateau,
recroquevillé dans un coin sec,
avant d'être secouru par Vincent Riou.
Allez, je m’arrête là.
On pourrait en parler pendant des heures
et il y a plein d'autres histoires.
Mais rendez-vous compte.
Quelle leçon !
Quelle leçon de vie !
Et j’ai très envie,
pour conclure cette histoire,
de vous citer Pip Hare qui, elle-même,
quand elle franchit le cap Horn,
déclare très joliment la chose suivante -
et je vais essayer
d’être fidèle à cette citation -
« Je constate que dans n’importe
quelle situation à bord,
qu’il s’agisse d’une tempête,
d’une fuite ou
de la réparation d’un safran,
on perd rapidement la vue d'ensemble.
Alors je suppose qu’il faut avoir la tête
dans les détails pour gérer les problèmes,
mais il est important aussi
de prendre de la hauteur
lorsque vous relèverez la tête à nouveau.
Car les tempêtes passent, le temps
change et les problèmes sont gérés.
Et ensuite, il faut continuer à avancer. »
Et vous ?
Vous aussi.
Après tout, vous êtes des héros.
Vous aussi, vous êtes certainement
encore en train de relever la tête,
de traverser des tempêtes et
des creux de plus de cinq mètres,
des hauts, des bas,
et des avaries en tout genre.
Et si ce que nous apprenait cette course,
ce n’était tout simplement pas
la vie ?
(Applaudissements)